بمنزلها الكائني بجهه حمام الانف في
محافظات بن عروس استقبلتنا السيده لطيفه
حامله صوره ابنها بين يديها وتخنقها
العبرات في حديثها عنه هي واحده من الاف
الامهات التي اكتوينا بنار الهجره غير
النظاميه
حكايتها تعود الى 12 سنه خلت عندما ركب
ابنها صبري احد قوارب الموت رغم تحصيله
شهاده جامعيه ومنذ ذلك الحنه وهي تنتظر
عودته
حاسي بودي ولو معه الى متى الانتظار صاحبي
انا المشكله
بين ضيفتي المتوسطي احلام جولي التونسيين
الباحثين عن مستقبل افضل احلام
الموت والهجره غير النظاميه جثث الالاف من
اصحابها في واحده من اقصى قصص المعاناه
الانسانيه التي قد لا تكفي المعالجه
الامنيه لايجاد حل لها قصه صبري والاف
المهاجرين غير نظامين تؤرق السلطات
التونسيه ونظيرتها الايطاليه وزير
الخارجيه والداخليه الايطاليين يحلان
بتونس وعلى طويله النقاش مع المسؤولين
التونسيين هذا الملف شائك امام رشح فهو
ضروره اعتماد مقاربه شامله لهذه الظاهره
تتجاوز البعد الامنيه
للهجره اكدنا مجددا انه يجب معالجته هذه
الظاهره من جذورها المشكله ليست امنيه فقط
رغم انها كذلك
يجب فهم الاسباب التي تدفع الالاف والالاف
لمغادره بلدانهم نحو الضفه الشماليه من
المتوسط وارغم هذه التاكيدات الرسميه تتهم
منظمات المجتمع المدني المعنيه بملف
الهجره تتهم سلطات التونسيه ونظراتها
الاوروبيه بعدم البحث عن اسبابها العميقه
وتوفير الاطر والاليات المناسبه لمعالجه
الظاهره
من السلطه خاصه الايطاليه
للحراسه
يعني هؤلاء الشباب
وبلغه الارقام وصلت 18000 تونسيه السنه
الماضيه الى سواحل الايطاليه فيما بلغ عدد
الواصلين خلال نصف الاول من يناير الحاليه
اكثر من الف و 1700 شخص وليد عبد الله
العربيه تونس